[Music]  so you're still amazing on this cover I  know it's not always all glam but do you  get a chance to like look at stuff like  that and be like you know what I look  fabulous it was like super quick so the  photographer is really great calm my  English was nice so I know you know  you're not gonna be a youngin for too  long you're about to turn 21 how do you  plan to celebrate oaky with the fam why  not right you know I love that you're so  open about those pesky dating rumors or  Tom Holland in this issue why was it  important you Billy hey guys come on  it's like my best friend  have you found that it's hard to date  Hollywood s oh yeah it's such a young  age it doesn't matter you know where you  are either I mean it's just hard to date  in general you know sometimes it's hard  to you know find people that you really  click with or really understand you and  add on top of the fact that my lifestyle  is very different so I mean is this  tough but I'm your catch girl  [Music]